بعد صدمه وحادثه وفاه شاب الجامعيه في
الاردن اثراء شردقه او غصه خلال تناوله
للطعام تقرير اطب الشرعي مشاهدينا اعاده
سبب الوفاء الى نقص بالتنفس الحاد بسبب
وجود بواقي طعام بمجرى التنفس الشردقه
بالطعام تحصل غالبا عند محاوله ابتلاع
لقمه كبيره قبل مضغها جيدا او عند الكلام
والضحك اثناء تناول الطعام واذا حدث
انسداد جزئي في مجرى التنفس بين المصاب
يستطيع ان يسعوا بقوه لازاله الجسم الغريب
من حلقه لكن قد يتحول الانسداد الجزئي الى
الانسداد كامل لمجرى التنفس عندها لا
يستطيع المصاب السعال ولا الكلام وقد يفقد
الوعي فكيف يمكن الوقايه من ذلك
[موسيقى]
معنى الان مشاهدينا في الاستوديو الدكتور
اكرم ابو دقن اخصائي طب الطوارئ اهلا بك
دكتور معنا حياك الله كل عام وانت بخير
طبعا كل عام وانتم بخير صباح هذا العيد
الجميل طيب دكتور موضوع الشردقه الحقيقه
يعني كنا دائما نسمع بانه يعني على طريق
الفكاهه انه ما تتشرداش دير بالك احسن ما
تروح فيها يعني ولكن هي حقيقه واقعه صارت
في الاردن وممكن اي حدا فينا يتعرض لها
خلينا نبدا مباشره شو هو الحل كيف بنعمل
الهايملك مانوفر في حال انه صار في
شردقه بانه ننقذ حياه هذا الشخص تمام
حقيقه هي الشردقه هي دخول الجسم اي جسم
غريب سواء قطعه لعبه ولا قطعه اكل دخلت
مجرى الهواء
فاحسن طريقه لتطلع هي السعال الطبيعي يعني
طريقه الجسم كيف تطلع هي سعال
فنحن لازم ما نتدخل يعني القواعد العامه
حنحكي بشكل بسيط ما نتدخل حتى نطلع هالجسم
الغريب بانفسنا نخلي الجسم هو يتعامل معها
لحتى يصير لمرحله معينه عندها هي المرحله
ممكن انه احنا نتدخل يعني
الواحد بصير في عنده سعال ضيقه نفس بيزرق
اذا كان طفل ممكن يصير ما يحكي ويكون شوي
متوتر وبلش يزرق ويبلش يحاول انه يسعل
بهاي المرحله اذا كنا عم نقدر نسمع السؤال
بس بنوقف جنب المريض وبنحاول نشجعه انه
يسعوا بشكل بشكل افضل وانه ما يخاف ونضلنا
جنبهم احنا جنبك بطريقه انه ما يخالف
تماما ولا بنضرب على ظهره ولا بنتدخل ابدا
لحد ما يوصل للمرحله التانيه شاعر يقول
الى الماء يسعى من يغصه بلقمه فالى اين
يسعى ممن يغص بماء هل من يغص بهذه اللقمه
الكبيره نعطيه مي يساعد ولا لا تماما انه
الشخص اللي عنده قصص اللي هو الشردقه او
الاختناق اللي بيعمل اختناق هو داخل الجسم
الغريب لمدخل طريق الهواء وليس الى المريء
القصص اللي نحن بنغسوا ونشرب مي هذاك
بنكون مثلا واحد عم ياكل ودخلت الاكل وما
عاد يقدر يبلع هذا اوكي بالمي بيمشي الحال
ولكن بس يكون في سؤال معناته احنا داخلين
بمجرى الهوى هون المي راح يعمل راح يعاكس
الاليه الطبيعيه اللي هي عم تنفذ الجسم
الغريب
تماما وحتى لما بتضرب على ظهر المريض
بيضربوه على ظهره هاي كمان ضربات هاي
الخفيفه هاي ممكن تخلي يعني يتشتت انتباهه
بدل ما يركز بالسؤال يصير بده انه تطلع
بهالطريقه وممكن تنزل لتحتك التدخل بيصير
بمرحله واحده بس يصير عندي السعال صامت
يعني المريض عم يحاول بس ما في صوت ما في
كلام ابدا هون احنا بنتدخل هذا يختلف بين
الكبار والصغار يختلف فوق السن وتحت السنه
احنا باقي لنا ثلاث دقائق بالنسبه للاطفال
هلا الطفل كان بلشي بلش بلش السعال يصير
الرضيع خلينا بلش السعال يصير صامت بلش
الولد يزرق مباشره
منحط الايد على راس الطفل راس الطفل
وكماله تساعد بتسند ظهره بهالطريقه وبنحطه
على رجلنا او اذا كنا على الارض
المنطقه بين حلمتي الثدي ناخذ اصبعتين
والراس بده يكون مستقيم ما يكون لانه مايل
قدام او لو رب يعني بشكل نوتشر يعني طبيعي
وبنضغط خمس ضغطات واحد ضغطات قوايا
بالمنتصف على خط حلمتي الثدي واحد اثنين
ثلاثه اربعه خمسه بعدين بنحط ايدنا على
وشه هيك بهالطريقه من الصندوق كمان بتساعد
الثاني حيكون ساند الصدر ومنقلبه بهي
الطريقه بنعمل الخمس ضربات الظهريه اللي
هن بين لوحي الكتف بين ثلاثه اربعه خمسه
بقوه هي الضربه نفس نظام لعبه البلياردو
لما بتضرب الكره والكره الثانيه نحن عم
نضرب عمرات طاقه الطاقه حتطلع الجسم
الغريب
اذا الواحد خاصه اذا الواحد كان ماله
متدرب كثير ولكن اذا بدي قارن اكسر له
ضلعه
للي اكبر نرجع بنقلبها هيك بس قبل ما نسكر
على الموضوع بنرجع بنقلبها هيك بهالطريقه
وبنرجع بنعمل خمسه
لحد ما نسمع سعاد او يبكي الولد او احيانا
نشوف الجسم الغريب بيطلع لبره تماما هلا
بالنسبه
بدنا
المتطوع شباب
متطوعين يلا
هلا هو اكيد اللي بكون غاصص عاده بشكل
عفوي بحط ايبادته وهي هي اسمها علامه
عالميه للقصص يعني انت بس تعمل هيك
الكادر وحده عامل كورس او حدا شيء بيعرف
انه هذا
فبدك اول شيء
اكيد يعني السؤال صامت يعني نحب مرحله
ثانيه الانسداد الكامل هو حيكون حاطط اذا
كان مو حاطط هون بدي انزل بين منطقه اسفل
الصدر هون في عظمه القص اخرها عند بدايه
ما يبدا البطن وبين السره حط ايدي بهي
الطريقه بسكر ايدي وحطها بهالمكان والايد
الثانيه وراها على راس المعده تمام بين
راس المعده وبين السره بالنص هلا الضغطه
بدها تكون لورا ولفوق يعني هيك كارف
منحنيه لفوق سوري
بس اقوى من هيك اقوى من هيك لاحظتو انه
لاحظتوا كيف الضغطه
السؤال مشان هيك بنقول بنضل عم نعمل هاي
الحركات لحتى يلفظ الجسم الغريب بالحالتين
من الضلع مندخل لحتى يلفظ الجسم الغريب او
انه يغيب عن الوعي تماما هلا اذا غاب عن
الوعي تماما سواء كبير او صغير بدنا نعمل
سي بي ار سي بي ار اللي هو راح ننزل
تماما هو غابه عن الوعيثه يكون واقف حنعمل
سي بي ار بين كمان تقريبا بمنتصف الصدر
بنعمل هدول الضغطات بنضلنا عم نضغط 30
ضغطه وبنفتح الفم بنحاول نعطي نفس اذا كان
بنفتح الفم اذا في جسم غريب برا بنحاول
نطلعه اذا ظاهر اذا ظاهر علي يعني مش انه
جسم غريب داخلي نستمر فيها الى حد يستفيق
او توصل الاسعاف ولذلك ذكرتنا عادل لازم
اول شغله نعملها انه نتصل بالاسعاف لانه
اذا ضلينا فايتين بهذا البروسيس وما اجى
الاسعاف ما حنعرف يعني بدنا حدا يكون عارف
انه في اصابه مبادئ اسعافات
شكرا جزيلا دكتور شكرا كل عام وانتم بخير
طب الطوارئ شكرا جزيلا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات